prince william and kate middleton share
a rare moment of pda at the polo cup as
he turns 40 william can reflect on a
brilliant thirties he's married very
happily married he's got someone who's a
supportive partner check out the duchess
of cambridge showing support for her
hubby at a charity polo match on
wednesday while serving a style moment
in an elegant white dress with black
stripes also keeping things comfortable
choosing flats for the outdoor outing
meanwhile william looks dapper in his
polo uniform and it turned out to be a
great day for the duke as his team won
and took home a trophy the couple share
a hug after william's big victory and at
one point william plants a kiss on his
wife's cheek
william has never been more confident
more happy
now kate and william seemed to be quite
the sports going couple lately the day
before his match the two attended
wimbledon which is an event they've been
going to together since 2011. kate and
william were seen in their royal box at
the quarterfinals of the annual tennis
tournament and brought their fashion a
game as usual kate sported a blue and
white polka dot dress while william wore
a windowpane suit jacket and tie
williams seems to be balancing business
and pleasure well since turning 40 last
month this will likely be the decade he
becomes the prince of wales this will
absolutely be the decade we're going to
see him lay down the foundation of a
future king and that foundation includes
philanthropy the homelessness has always
stuck with me as a topic and as an issue
i want to fight for leading up to his
milestone birthday the royal hit the
streets to sell copies of the big issue
magazine a publication sold by the
homeless and long-term unemployed
william shared that he first visited a
homeless shelter when he was 11
alongside his late mother princess diana
and now he feels inspired to carry on
her legacy by giving back i think
william recognises that his father can
through age alone only really be a
transitional king the future of the
monarchy the future of the house of
windsor very much on williams shoulders
it was something he struggled with as a
young man but i think if he approaches
40 with kate by his side his three
children work life balance which somehow
he's really much to strive i think he
feels optimistic about the future and i
think in terms of the future of the
monarchy william is
[Music]
you